thank you
[Music]
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk TV
[Music]
tonight up here's Welcome to our
censored teachers vote to join half a
million workers in the biggest day of
industrial action for a generation but
after years of covered hell of the
unions Now using children as bargaining
chips are taught live to the union boss
found in the shutdown schools
a more tragedy in Ukraine as three
members of the government Diner
helicopter crash almost a year into this
war how and when will The Suffering end
I'll ask America's former CIA Chief Leon
Panetta
and Madonna announces a new world tour
with her most gruesome revolting
attention-seeking video ever and the bar
was very high for that title is she
blazing a trail of a growing old with
grammar gracefully or as I think she is
is she just an old hot mess we'll debate
that later
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored
good evening from London and welcome to
Piers Morgan on Center Britain's winter
of discontent in 1979 was defined by
mass industrial action soaring inflation
freezing temperatures and a chaotic
government gasping its last breaths
sounds familiar doesn't it nurses are
striking again today next week is train
drivers again airport staff again civil
servants again half a million workers
will walk out on Wednesday it's the
biggest day of coordinated strikes since
that miserable winter of 1979 and this
time they'll be joined on the picket
Lines by teachers 23 000 schools may be
forced to close that will mean
inevitable chaos for millions of parents
who don't forget are facing the exact
same wage squeeze and soaring bills as
the teachers now they'll be forced to
stay at home miss work and Heat their
homes at a vast expense in some cases
this is the current education secretary
Jillian Keegan
we do need to keep teachers and children
in school and I will work with you know
you don't need to strike to get my
attention I will meet with people I'll
be as constructive as possible but we do
need to be fair and and the the number
one thing we need to do is total
inflation I've said that to you before
there's no point what we need to do is
halve inflation that's obviously what
what we've said will do and go be
further Beyond be you know more than
that
sounds like a little old waffle to me
part of the problem is they don't know
whose attention they need to get she's
the fifth education secretary in a year
this just doesn't feel like a government
that's taking education seriously but
clearly neither of the unions today they
said striking teachers shouldn't even
bother to provide online lessons for the
children stuck at home and so while
parents will be hit by the literal cost
of a strike the real burden will fall
again on the children
the covered lockdowns were devastating
for kids we know that they were the
least at risk from the virus that
transpired but they paid arguably the
highest price now just as they begin to
recover and many of them way behind
where they should be in their education
they're being used as a bargaining chip
in a political game I understand the
teachers feel messed around I also
understand that they play an
indispensable role in society a few
things are more important than
children's education that's precisely
why these strikes to me feel selfish and
wrong
well joining me now talk to people
editor Kate McCann the science political
sketch writer quentinlets and Daily
Mirror associate editor Kevin McGuire
and Kevin Courtney The Joint General
Secretary of a National Education Union
we'll get in Courtney thank you for
joining me
um so look you represent a large number
of teachers in this country more than
300 000 of your members were asked to
vote but only 54 of them actually voted
why why did the other 46 not vote
it was the biggest Union ballot result
since the government changed the law on
those thresholds in 2016 there would
have been more votes if we were allowed
to conduct our votes electronically like
we know is safe and possible there would
have been more votes if we could have
voted at work but this is an
overwhelming result is and since we
announced the result about 10 000 more
people have joined the union there's a
lot of support amongst teachers in the
classroom for the action that we're
preparing
I don't understand okay here's my point
really when I saw those numbers I just
thought of myself well if if the
situation is that dire in schools and
amongst teachers if it's that awful
if it's so so bad why did 46 of teachers
not even bother to vote
well it is bad one in eight leave in
their first year of teaching one in
eight maths lessons are being taught by
somebody who isn't qualified in maths a
quarter of physics lessons are being
taught by somebody who haven't got a
degree or a postgraduate qualification
in physics so it is bad and the result
that we've scored is the biggest ballot
result of any Union since the laws were
changed and that's what you've got to
get your head rump is 10 000 people have
joined our Union since we made the
announcement the action will be very
popular and popular amongst those uh
members who want us to want to see us
making a step well the action will be
possible
education
yeah the strikes will be popular amongst
your members who voted to strike but
let's be clear that is not every teacher
clearly by the Numbers I've just
expressed and I'm also you know I've got
to say this I've got a lot of sympathy
for teachers and I'm sure like all
public sector workers they feel
aggrieved about their financial
situation because inflation is Raging so
high but if you take average pay across
the public sector teachers aren't doing
that badly comparative to ambulance
workers rail travel assistants nurses
teachers come in about 38
982 pounds on average and they did get a
pay rise last year between five and
eight percent so when it comes to
dishing out very valuable pounds to
people in the public sector I've got to
say I don't think teachers for those
reasons would be top of my list or even
in the middle of the list they'd be
frankly compared to nurses and other
more deserving cases they'd be nearer
the bottom explain to me why I'm wrong
well the institute for fiscal studies
issued a report last week looking at the
relative pay of teachers and and they
said that teacher pay had declined by 13
since 2010 whereas average pay in the
economy had gone up by two percent and
they pointed to that relative decline of
teacher pay as a fundamental explanation
of why it is so difficult to get people
to come into the job and why we're not
holding people in the job so when you
say peers that other people are more
deserving I I want you to think about
the fact that we don't have special
needs assistance for children with
special needs because they're getting
jobs that are paid better in in
supermarkets I want you to think about
the fact that we don't have qualified
maths teachers in many classes up and
down up and around the country I want
you to think about the fact that we
haven't got DT teachers design and
technology or Computing teachers and I
also want you to think about the fact
that some people who are wealthy enough
can get can escape that problem by going
to private school
I'm sympathetic to teachers at all I
value good teachers but I'm also want
you to to hear and to understand what
many parents say to me which is through
the pandemic their kids regressed they
just weren't getting proper education in
many cases they weren't getting the
online education that was promised to
them their kids often didn't get
anything so they feel aggrieved about
the lack of care and attention their
kids have had academically and
educationally in the last three years
the very last thing that they want these
parents is to now go back to a situation
of mini lockdown again where the kids
get told to stay at home and again
cannot get the education they
desperately need just to catch up from
where they've been left behind by the
pandemic
well I absolutely agree with you we do
not want to disrupt education we want
the government instead to come to a
settlement with us but it's my
experience that Jillian Keegan actually
doesn't talk and doesn't listen until
there is a threat of industrial action
and so I think the threat of industrial
action is really important in getting
the government to concentrate on the
crisis in our schools and thinking
through that they have to put it right
just like the industrial action by the
nurses and the ambulance workers is
making them concentrate on the crisis in
our National Health Service and the and
the need that they have to put that
right all right well listen I appreciate
you joining me Kevin Courtney and I hope
you come to resolution before the
strikes that's what the country wants
parents have suffered enough the kids
are certainly suffered enough but I
appreciate you joining the show thank
you
all right probably you have a two-way
there where they go thank you but not in
that case we waited and we waited and we
waited but there's nothing going it
hasn't been properly taught he'd been
immobilized by the power of my rhetoric
uh I saw you I saw you two basically
grimacing and shaking your heads oh let
me stop okay Quincy start with you well
he says we don't want to disrupt
education but it's you know they plainly
do because they're choosing to go on
strike so the palpable lie sorry untrust
um teachers are reasonably well paid
they are paid more than most of the
parents got a good pay rise last year
comparative to many in the public sector
you didn't mention their pensions
fantastic pensions uh they get they
don't have to work all year because they
get long holidays free grub at the in
the in the dining room and uh
I I mean that one's heart goes out to
some parts of the public sector but not
to teachers indolent that instinctively
that's my problem here okay is I just
think there are more deserving people
not least the nurses who've not had the
kind of average pay not had the kind of
recent pay rise of the teachers I don't
think public sympathy is going to be
there in the same numbers for teachers
as it has been for nurses well it isn't
polling shows that it isn't although I
think it's fair to say that people don't
necessarily accept the government's
argument that they are operating within
a closed window of money they think that
the government could potentially offer
more but I think some of the points that
were made there about Julian Keegan I
mean those talks between the unions and
the Secretary of State have actually
been relatively good in fact one of the
first things that Julian Keegan did when
she came into office was give teachers
the two billion pounds that they had
asked for now that's what the government
is saying is one of the reasons why they
don't want to talk about pay because
they did revise their payoffer for 22
2022 and then they gave the additional
cash that was asked for I think the
problem really is Nurses and I know it's
something that we are going to come on
to talk about but that's the real
sticking point where the government's
argument I think for many people doesn't
stack up about the cash Kevin you
obviously want to give all of them
everything they're asking for because
you're a good union boy to your military
bootstraps no but is there even in your
eyes a a ranking of priorities here and
where do teachers fall yeah but peers
you can see why they want to try and
restore their pay when he's right The
Institute of fiscal studies are
respected their pay is down between 10
and 13 in real estate
nurses are down about 10 but when
inflation is Raging at over 10 percent
what can any government do you can't
give them all enough to cover inflation
inflation raging is why your living
standards are falling an increase for
for teachers isn't in directly
inflationary because you don't put up
the price of Education because we don't
charge for it for the 93 used State
schools if you take the Oliver Twist
approach with his government you go
please sir may I have some more you'll
get very thin gruel and he's right and
it's it's unfortunate that if you ballot
and you take industrial action you cause
disruption you will get greater
attention the rail unions are getting
higher offers finally and some of the
strings that the government were
attached are being cut so there may be a
deal there you say rank them yeah nurses
I can I can see why nurses will be the
top of the tree most of them earn less
than 31 000 pounds their pay is down
about 10 since uh 2010. I can see why
there is no sympathy for them but let's
not let's not forget there will be huge
sympathy for teachers because they
communicate with parents all the time
and Jillian Keegan that she talks to
them but she's not negotiating with them
I don't think I don't think so she's not
allowed I don't think she wore a ten
thousand pound Rolex watch the last time
she saw the much she did previously so
yeah she can she can smile at him be
nice and it can be all polite back and
it can all be convivial but I can't see
an end to this we're going to keep you
guys obviously for the rest of the show
but just quickly Madonna
in my opinion hot mess should be put out
to pasture your view I love the way
she's growing old disgracefully she's 64
or most of her is and I like the way
she's carrying it off with your mother
or grandmother well that would be
different right grandmother actually be
biologically impossible great
grandmother all right then okay are you
a Madonna fan I mean I don't have a
strong abuse as you I like to watch you
have views on Madonna
you have very strong I don't really have
it I don't know she's the new Vera Lynn
she is she's as old now as Vera Lynn was
when we were uh youngsters yes in the
1980s
virulin had Grace and dignity
yeah Madonna has nothing what I'm just
trying to say is I think she's she's had
a day she's a great performer come on
she she used to be passing she used to
be but it's embarrassing the the whole
trying to be a sex kitten thing when
you're in your mid-60s let's have a look
at some of her greatest hits my idea of
her greatest hits
have we got it
no no not the actual Greatest Hits I
mean the video matched up of her
excruciating moments have we got that
here we go
they're saying fill it out please be
well expecting because I can't surprise
him in the gallery you could download
better off Amy Schumer oh truth or dare
dare I want you to show me with this
spread how you lick your husband's
all right
I dare you to do a world tour and play
your greatest
hits that's a lot of songs it's a lot of
songs you think people would come to
that show I'll be there well I'll be
there okay so the answer is
yeah I mean some very little renders me
speechless I can tell you but that that
does and we'll have more of Madonna's
well her recent catalog in recent years
is unbelievably cringe making things
that is by far the worst
um but anyway she's I'll just show you
one picture which sums up my view it's
this one
no so one have you got the one of her
lying under the bed
that one there we go that now that to me
that my headline would be rock bottom
and that's it she dropped her false
teeth under the bed
to us all absolutely Grinch monkey uh
all right we're going to talk about
McDonald's on the show but after the
break we could talk to Leon Panetta
about what's happening in Ukraine he
couldn't get many more credible people
than him former CIA director about what
is happening now what can they do
ukrainians what can we do to help them
and what is Putin planning you keep
being told he's planning some massive
new offensive what do we do about it
better off the brain
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
well welcome back our Ukraine is
grieving again tonight after three
senior members whose government died on
a helicopter crash almost a year into a
war the Vladimir Putin thought to be
over in days and that's a credit to both
Ukraine's resolve and to the West's
support but there's no end in sight and
the casualties tragically continue to
mount so how and when does it end well
I'm still at my pack with me but I'm
also joined I'm glad to say all right
Leon Panetta the former director of the
CIA and former Defense secretary in
America Mr Bernard thank you very much
indeed for joining me again on the show
we appreciate it
um we've talked before about Ukraine I
saw the president zielinski was a Davos
giving he was talking to the people at
Davos saying this this has to end
but how do you see this ending
well I think it's very important at a
critical point in this war and it is a
critical point uh because uh it appears
to be a stalemate right now on the
ground uh in many ways I'm concerned
that it may favor uh the Russians uh and
the aggressor and allow them to dig in
to reinforce and to prepare for an
offensive so I think it's very important
now for the Allies to provide uh the
weapons that are essential to the
ukrainians uh heavy tanks missiles air
defense all of that ought to be provided
now uh in a
in an effort to try to give them the
ability to get the edge on an offensive
against the Russians this cannot be
allowed just simply to drag on uh that's
not going to that's not going to help
either party very frankly uh in terms of
trying to achieve uh some kind of ending
to this war
Britain is sending 12 tanks we know
others will be doing the same I mean
it's a very fine line isn't there
between supporting Ukraine in this
manner and actively engaging in this war
is it a line that the Russians May
deliberately blur are they trying to
indicate now that they may widen the war
if the West continues to support Ukraine
in a more direct manner
you know for for a year uh Russia has
threatened all kinds of consequences uh
that's the way they behave that's the
way Putin behaves uh and frankly we've
gone ahead regardless of those threats
and provided the weapons and provided
the support that is essential to the
ukrainians and I think we have to
continue to do that look the fundamental
issue is that we are fighting uh by
supporting Ukraine and the ukrainians
who are fighting this War uh it's one of
the most important Wars of the 21st
century because in many ways the outcome
of this war will tell us a great deal
about what ultimately happens to
democracies in the 21st century so we
have a lot writing on making sure that
Ukraine is successful in this war there
was a hideous attack a few days ago in
the knee Pro on a residential block
gruesome videos I want to play a little
bit of one just to indicate the horror
of what is actually happening thing on
the ground there
is
I mean this is in the middle of a
sovereign Democratic country's City
and over 40 people were killed in an
attack on a residential building
I mean Mr Panetta wouldn't you see
something like that what are we seeing
here are these just war crimes
I think what we're seeing is uh the
Russians very clearly indicating that
they're not winning this war
and as a result they're going after
innocent men women and children uh and
conducting these kinds of horrific
attacks against uh innocent individuals
for me it's a reflection that Russia is
not winning but losing this War uh and I
think as a result of that the Allies
really need air defense systems we need
longer range missiles in order to make
sure that Russia uh their will to
continue to fight is broken Russia is
trying to
hope that somehow the will of the West
may break we have to basically provide
the support system to the ukrainians to
break the will of the Russians yeah I
completely agree there are two more
things in order to just to get your
perspective on uh one is Prince Harry
the Duke of Sussex has run into trouble
diplomatically now in this country from
his base in America with this book is
written in which he talked about killing
25 Taliban in Afghanistan and he
described you know what people have
accused him of being of dehumanizing
Enemy by describing them as chess pieces
not human beings to be removed from a
board and it's part of a reaction
predictable reaction from the Taliban uh
exploiting what he said but it also is
now uh inspired a reaction from Iran who
executed a British Iranian on uh trump
top suggestions he was a spy and have
issued a statement off the back of what
Harry said in Return for the criticism
about the execution to say the the
British regime his royal family member
seized the killing of 25 innocent people
as removal of chess pieces and has no
regrets over the issue and those who
turn a blind eye to this war crime are
in no position to preach others on human
rights what's your view about that was
Harry very misguided to put into a book
that sold as many as it has done an
exact number of Taliban he killed and to
describe them as chess pieces
well appears based on based on my
experience uh uh both uh in the military
and as a secretary of defense
I have to tell you that the strongest
Warriors I knew in battle
were those who focused on the mission
uh and not uh how many uh individuals on
the other side that they killed they
focused on whether or not the mission
was accomplished uh and I think Prince
Harry would have done better to focus on
the missions that he was involved with
rather than counting the number of debt
so I I think in this situation
obviously Iran is is not a country uh
with a strong human rights record so
whatever they say I think uh we're not
to really pay a lot of attention to but
I do think that he could have handled
this better as a soldier would it be
sensible or be it he's already said this
but would it be sensible for future
editions of the book is it reprinting as
we speak and given the volume that it's
selling would it be sensible for him to
maybe issue a statement to calm things
down to express some regret over putting
a number to his his Taliban and kill
tally and to call them chess pieces and
to actually remove that part from the
book
yeah you know I
I think that
when you you start to detail how many
have been killed then in some ways that
becomes the issue and what I'm offended
by frankly is the Distortion of focusing
on numbers of killed rather than the
mission that he was involved with which
I think was a was a strong Mission an
important mission to go after the
Taliban and those who were involved in
the attack on 9 11. this was a this was
an important Mission and that's what
ought to be focused on so if in some way
he could kind of
rewrite this or or include the missions
that he was involved in without
referring to the number of people that
were killed I think that would frankly
represent a fairer description of what
he was involved with in his service I I
look he he I'm sure he performed well
I'm sure he did his service to his
country uh and I think that's important
but I think saying uh the number of
people that were killed frankly detracts
both from the mission and from the
service that he provided yeah I agree uh
finally uh big story of being brewing in
America in the last few days about
President Biden and classified documents
have been found at his home obviously we
had this with President Trump an ongoing
investigation into that you were
obviously uh worked under the Obama by
the administration what is your view of
this I mean is there any qualitative
difference between the two presidents
here and how they've mishandled
classified documents and what should
happen to uh President Biden
well there is a concern here when you're
dealing with classified documents the
reality is that these documents require
that they be handled carefully that they
may be logged in and that they be secure
and for whatever reason that did not
happen it didn't happen with President
Trump uh in a very Reckless way frankly
in terms of the numbers of the documents
that are involved here and to the same
extent uh you know President Biden made
a mistake here uh and there was a
mistake either on his part or on the
status part for not being able to secure
those documents so I think the
appointment of a special console in both
cases is appropriate we need to find out
what happened or we need to make sure
that it never happens again uh and so it
is it does detract from uh frankly uh
you know President Biden's effort to try
to say that what president Trump did was
wrong uh the fact is what he did is not
correct either so both are going to have
to face the consequences for the way
they mishandled classified documents
it's always good to have you on the
program because you always answer
questions honestly and directly and I
really appreciate it it's a rarity in
public life these days so please come
back again soon I appreciate it
thank you pierce good to talk to you all
the best
we're going to get a reaction to that
from my pack after the break I'm going
to talk about Madonna and this new world
tour you know My Views one crinkly hot
mess
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is talk TV
[Music]
well we'll come to the slow-moving train
wreck of Madonna in a moment I want to
get the Pax reaction first of all to the
Leon Panetta very interesting interview
uh Kate because like I said to him he
gives a straight answer to a straight
question I mean on both things he will
have made news I think both the
criticism of Joe Biden and we used to
work obviously under but I'll start
first of all with this Prince Harry
situation where a lot of our enemies are
now using his words to try and play
moral equivalents with their own
disregard for human life and it's
because he showed himself in the book A
disregard for human life in both naming
the tally and probably more pertinently
calling them chess pieces not human
beings
how does this play out do you think
because at the moment it's a growing
International route isn't it I wonder if
there has already been some discussion
behind closed doors about what to do
about that particular part of the book
because of the reaction to it I mean it
would obviously be a significant climb
down and I imagine that he probably
wouldn't want to go there to have to
remove something from the book as
written but I mean those comments to you
were completely clear it would be good
to articulate The Wider mission to set
it in context I mean I think there is
context in the book there is more
context than just the numbers there is
but what he was very disingenuous about
Quincy was as he always does he
immediately passed the buck for any
blame from himself and what he'd said
putting the the figure in there calling
them chess pieces it all became an ugly
evil plot by the vile British press oh
yeah and once again misconstrue what he
meant and he slags off the press of
making mistakes and saying they should
always retract and say sorry and yet he
never does the same thing we've just
heard a respected Statesman uh retired
Statesman of American politics basically
said
that Prince Harry is a glumping idiot
yeah and um worse than that he's
completely out of his depth and he's an
important uh issues and the Americans
are horrified to see anyone giving the
Iranians any excuse to miss Behavior you
know what's interesting Uh Kevin is is
they've been relying I think or they
think they know they burn their bridges
in this country these two they're living
in California they've been playing the
whole media circuit out there in America
but a new poll in Newsweek uh showing
massively falling approval ratings for
both Prince Harry and Meghan Markle in
America I mean the numbers are really
quite startling uh Harry was liked by 31
and disliked by 38 which is way down on
even December so just before the book
came out Meghan Markle the same both
showing a lot of negativity now in the
country where they need to be popular
yeah well I think the royal family is
more more popular than they are which
will probably come a shotgun but it will
hurt them more what happens in the US
and here and they can you can slack off
and machine on the the press and the
media here but when you have a former
U.S defense secretary in your new home
yeah saying look I mean you effectively
caught marshaled him and found him
guilty yes have been absolutely yeah I
was quite surprised how far he went I
think it's too late to take the figure
out actually he's not going to take it
out this will be such a climbed up but
the damage the damage is done although
personally I quite like his account of
what war is like just as we saw the
video the video what happened in Ukraine
here's a different killing the Taliban
was a dirty yeah but here's the thing
Kevin you won't meet anyone in the
military honestly that does that in
public you know my brother's a just
recent retired army colonel my
brother-in-law army colonel they just
don't talk they both served in
Afghanistan and Iraq they just don't
talk like that way his friends have said
the same yeah it's something that you
just don't do you just don't do it in
public you just don't and you certainly
don't do it in order to earn millions of
dollars right well that's I think that's
the point that's true he didn't do it he
didn't do it for the public good you did
it he did it for his own main balance uh
we're gonna come to Madonna now I've
been teasing this also she of course was
a big pop star back in the age years I
went to see her at Wembley Stadium
actually in the Holiday Tour and she was
fantastic but then that was about 40
years ago and neither of us have aged
particularly well I would argue I've
aged slightly better than Madonna but uh
in recent years is this autocue going to
move well I'm gonna have to make another
thing I don't mind uh she's oh she lost
the plot let's take a look
in this room all bets are off Amy
Schumer oh truth or dare dare I want you
to show me with this spread how you lick
your husband's
I can't take any more of it I'm sorry
you know watching someone in their 60s
behaving like that we've got this other
little hit and miss yeah these are some
of the greatest hits
yeah one under the bed drop the bottom
and so on
just general this has been basically
what she's been putting out now for
several years and I'm sorry it's just
there's got to be an end to this isn't
there
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
let me talk to both of you uh first of
all you Louis Walsh you want to defend
the indefensible come on mate it's all
over isn't it for Madonna it's
embarrassing
it's not all over there's no way she's
her tour is going to sell out you just
watch they'll be adding extra dates in
every city this is the greatest theater
I I would go there absolutely she's
iconic she's one of our biggest pop
stars ever you just don't like her no no
it's not that actually I don't even care
I don't need to like singers to enjoy
them at all in fact quite the opposite I
don't need to like any artist to enjoy
them but in her case I find her behavior
for a woman in her 60s just utterly
embarrassing I mean if that was my
mother or whatever you'd be like
cringing
appears you're doing exactly what she
wants you to do you're talking about her
she's controversial she's always in the
news she's her own best PR person and
listen this tour is going to be massive
whether you like it or not
well I don't doubt it'll be a success a
bit like Prince Harry's book I don't
doubt it'll be successful it's just
unbelievably disgraceful let me bring it
I'm right Hans I mean you're a you're a
young woman I mean is this how you'd
like to be in your 60s
absolutely no I think the whole thing is
really bizarre I don't know why we're
celebrating this she looks like she has
potentially a mental health problem I'm
not sure why she's unable to just get
old gracefully her face looks deformed
unfortunately and I don't know why we're
celebrating this we live in a time where
people talk about body positivity but
she's unable to just accept herself and
grow old gracefully the video was
incredibly crass and I think the whole
thing is part of a much wider again
political feminist statement to say
women can go on for years being
sexualized and doing whatever they want
and you know the society is going to
love them for and it's not true I don't
really understand why she's not spending
this time in you know her later years
she's mid 60s now with her kids with her
grandkids maybe teaching them everything
she's learned in the music business or
in life over the last time I totally
agree I mean Louie Louie I'm not being
funny but imagine being one of her kids
right so the sheer volume of
embarrassing stuff that your mother
posts on Instagram and whatever and you
just
for them that's your biggest school
loving to deal with that there's that's
her job she is the Queen of Pop she has
millions of followers all around the
world they're all going to buy our
tickets this is going to be one of the
biggest tours of the Year absolutely now
I know she's not in a great place
physically because the last time she was
touring I was in Miami I was in the cube
outside and she canceled the gig because
she wasn't in a good place right but I
would go and see her again this is like
a greatest hits to repairs why can't she
go and do the equivalent of a pipe and
slippers just go and you know put on a
lot of clothing go and sit in a rocking
chair and just do the old hits from a
chair no no she could go to Vegas and do
a table she's gone all around the world
this is going to be massive appears it's
going to be controversial but she's a
great performer she's a great singer
you're not a target audience let's be
honest both of you I believe I'm not a
saga audience lay a final word to you I
mean will you go and watch this show
I definitely am not gonna go watch it I
see no difference between what she's
doing showing her body off to the entire
world in the most
um disgusting fashion to mothers on only
fans and how their kids feel in school
totally inappropriate um and I think
it's quite disgusting all grandmothers
on only fans I think we could raise them
exactly uh listen Louis I appreciate
your efforts to defending defensible but
I'm not buying it uh Leia thank you you
spoke Common Sense on the matter uh
unfortunately it will be a Smash Hit
This tour and people will go but then
people like to look at car crashes on a
Motorway uh good to talk to you both
thank you very much indeed coming next
the most watched woman on cable news in
America Laura Ingram will be here to
give her take on President Biden's
classified documents drama and what it
might mean for Donald Trump's chances of
returning to the White House
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to peers working on
censored us Democrats are scrambling to
minimize the Fallout from a discovery of
classified documents of President
Biden's home and former office Leon
Panetta the former CIA Chief Tommy out
of the Biden made a mistake so would it
harm Biden's re-election plans and does
it get Trump off the hook well joining
me now is the most watched woman in
cable news in America Fox News host and
Superstar Laura Ingram Laura your debut
on Piers Morgan uncensored I can't think
of anybody better to be on the show than
someone as uncensored as you
thank you it's great to be here two
quick questions before we get to the
classified documents
um two people we've been talking about
in the show so far Prince Harry what is
your view of these two Harry and Megan
because apparently their approval
ratings plummeting Now in America
according to a Newsweek poll out today
well you know I always I use my 17 year
old daughter as a good barometer for
what she thinks of you know the
celebrity set
and I asked her I said Maria you know
what do you think you've been reading
all this stuff about Harry and Megan and
my daughter said well Megan's really
pretty you know I like her clothes but
he seems like a real wuss
that's a 17 year old's opinion of what
is going on here and I think that kind
of sums it up for a lot of people I mean
it seems that the queen when she passed
on it brought back I think everything
that you know we love about tradition
and respect and Duty service to Country
service to nation and she really
epitomized that and that was such a
wonderful tribute and send off to her uh
almost an era gone by and he is kind of
representing almost 180 degree opposite
at least in this period I'm not talking
about when he was in the military or any
of that but in this period a lack of
gratitude a lack of concern for uh his
family I I I like the people who kind of
keep it inside the family explain to
your family yeah complain within the
walls of the family otherwise lose the
title and don't completely agree if you
don't like it give up the titles and
just be the new Kardashians it's fine
um talking you're keeping things inside
Madonna
New World Tour I have a view it's not a
very favorable view uh I think she's a
crinkly hot mess you'll take
well I'm glad you're bringing me on to
talk about the issues that I spend my
time focused on because this is why I
love you you never know what you're
gonna get on this show okay well I I was
in college when Material Girl was the
big hit right so we'd be dancing the
fraternities the dart method was a blast
you know it was that era and it was a
fun kind of iconoclastic era well I hate
to break the news to Madonna but that
era is over yes and it there's no
there's no amount of kind of physical
transformation that's her that's her
business whatever she wants to do with
that but at some point like we all have
to kind of realize we're not 25 anymore
we're not 35 we're not 45. kind of act
your age have fun enjoy yourself but I
think everyone from from Tina Turner
Turner to uh you know Aretha Franklin
they understood how to how to progress
with age and be really cool and classy
you know you know Donna Summers like all
the great uh recording artists were able
to do that and and I think it's maybe a
little bit difficult for some people but
at some point it becomes a little bit
embarrassing I completely agree right
let's get to where you thought you were
on Piers Morgan on census tonight which
is the I'd like to jump in because you
were so good off the cuff anyway I could
ask you anything but this issue of the
classified documents two things about it
Leon Panetta to my surprise just now
said this let's play a little clip
it does detract from uh frankly uh you
know President Biden's effort to try to
uh say that uh what president Trump did
was wrong uh the fact is what he did is
not correct either so both are going to
have to face the consequences for the
way they mishandled classified documents
I've been interesting from Panetta there
I thought given that he worked our
course on the administration uh Biden
and Obama
um in a way I mean Biden's obviously
he's lost a moral ground on this it
might be more serious we don't know yet
what the consequences will be but a what
do you think about the implications for
him but also what does it mean for Trump
who was obviously very beleaguered on
this very issue but now perhaps not so
exposed
well a very interesting poll again it's
it's a snapshot we don't know exactly
what it means long term but an
interesting poll came out today by
morning consult it's a it's a fairly
well respected poll in the United States
and Trump and it was a Republican
primary poll and Trump's favorables I
believe were 50 which was the highest I
mean I'm talking about overall voters
um the highest they've been in quite a
long time and he trounces DeSantis by 17
points some other polls uh showed
DeSantis and Trump very close together
or even some cases DeSantis ahead of
trump so it might be that people are
beginning to see that you know all the
so-called controversies that people
think we got them this time we got them
this time that this is kind of another
one of those and uh that in in tough
times there's still a quite a hardcore
group of Republicans in the United
States who think that Trump is the only
guy to be able to take on the swamp he
knows where the bodies are buried now
and uh he he'll know how to hire people
uh right off the bat and maybe have his
priorities straight right off the bat
that's what I'm hearing from a lot of
people but it's way early I know that
sounds like a cop-out but it really is
it really is way early but I think on
this issue yeah I'm half expecting you
know Biden to find you know some
documents in his dog's bed or something
at this point like who knows who knows I
mean I'm that dog that kept biting
people it's back in Wilmington dude I
think the dog ate the documents
it could go anywhere uh Laura thank you
so much for joining me I really
appreciate it uh the Lord I'm a big fan
well I'm a big fan that's a big fan of
yours Mutual big fast right back at you
it's great to have you on the show thank
you very much
you're welcome
we're still with the pack so look just
unpack a few things here first of all
quick take on Madonna
I think you've heard the evidence
foreign against I I don't have very
strict views on on this Madonna creature
but um uh it does strike me that I mean
she's so old when she goes on stage I
think the John's ambulance Brigade need
to be crouching in the slips they could
they could have a busy night okay you
raise an interesting question in the
commercial break yeah I want to know
when you're going to put my body on
lockdown at what age at what age am I
trying to give you a specific answer
well I think you ought to 53 why 53 I
just made it up but I mean isn't there a
moment when as Laura rightly said women
and men I think the same way when I see
men prancing around all their clothes
off at the age of 67 to a rock stage
they get too old for it the stick
doesn't work women should like men grow
old with some gracious why why should
why should we why not why should we
because
the younger people who have the
aesthetic ability to show it off we sow
less and less as we get older but why
well apart for anything else the old
style you know we just lost a Italian
beauty what was her name right and there
was a real Beauty as she got older less
was more less okay but so why is older
not beautiful because things sag old is
beautiful but you're saying but hang on
you're saying when you're young and
beautiful I don't mind
you wouldn't prance around like she's
making the argument that I would I'm not
suggested
yeah I might might change my mind when
I'm older I'm saying she has every right
to do that but I'm more interested in
why you think because she's an older
lady it's not attractive I think older
men as well okay
yeah but you don't pick on older men in
the same way do you appears I do yeah
we're gonna go a cliff Richard Elton
John Paul McCartney Oh Cliff doesn't
dress up
now there's a sign figure of a man
I mean that is yeah
a funny little twist of that tale uh
obviously that wasn't actually my body
it was a Burger King stunt
my Elder my eldest son was on holiday in
Barbados three weeks ago and a guy came
up to him in a bar and said I'm your
father's body double yeah and it was the
guy who'd actually done that suit with
Burger King uh I never told people it
was a fake obviously he gets on it
pretty hot in it but there we are
on this other issue in the paper today
question I thought of you know I read it
this issue of cake
apparently the main problem
the main problem with the beast in
Britain is that we eat too much cake and
our colleagues our work colleagues like
these
fattening cakes and they make us eat it
against our wishes passive smoking and
that is the big promise it's bad as
smoking absolutely nonsense this is just
the complete bossy boots of uh of
officialdom coming out and telling us we
can't even have office cake nowadays I
just I think they're completely out of
touch uh with uh the relaxed nature of
the British here's the thing someone's
put a cake in front of me it's one of my
work colleagues I don't have to eat it
in fact I'm in a new year new peers mode
at the moment no cake will enter my
mouth but here's the point it's my
choice and in the end the government
could say well they had it lies bringing
cake in or out of work makes no
difference it's your ability to deny
taking a big slab of it sticking it in
your Gully if you can stop that enough
times you will lose weight Kate but I
mean the argument that the argument that
she was actually making was that I mean
the stats hit two-thirds of us are
overweight I mean that that that's
normal are you so why are you saying us
because I'm talking about the population
two-thirds of the population in this
country are overweight most kids when
they go to Primary School a lot of the
problem is not people bringing in a
birthday cake at work no but I think the
point that she's making sorry is that it
when you talk about people being able to
stop eating actually for some people
that's really hard
she didn't say eating cake at work and
passive smoking were identical
but she was making a point that 30 000
people a year die in Britain yeah with
with overweight and obesity an issue
passive smoking's down at 10 000 most of
that's in the home so yeah
and I have to inhale it right you're not
going to inhale my cake
sitting two feet away you can be tempted
the other thing is who really gets
killed he got worse
and it's wrong to say stop the meeting
leave cake out of it thank you Pat
you've been great what have you up to
tonight Keep It Uncensored but not as
unsensitive as Madonna if you're Madonna
keep it sensitive good night
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]